[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the next day
the sun shone and coraline's mother took
her into the nearest large town to buy
some clothes for school
they dropped her father off at the
railway station he was coming into
london for the day to see some people
coraline waved him goodbye they went to
the department store to buy some
clothes for school coraline saw some
dayglow green gloves she liked a lot
her mother refused to buy them for her
preferring instead to buy some white
socks
navy blue squirt underpants four grey
blouses and a dark grey skirt but mum
everybody at school has got grey blouses
and everything nobody's got green gloves
i could be the only one her mother
ignored her
she was talking to the shop assistant
they were talking about which kind of
sweater to get for coraline
and were agreeing that the best thing to
do would be to get one that was
embarrassing large and baggy
in the hopes that one day she just might
grow into it curling wandered off
and looked at a display of wellington
boots shaped like frogs and ducks and
rabbits
then she wandered back carl i know there
you are
where on earth were you i was kidnapped
by aliens
so coraline they came down from outer
space with raygrounds but i fooled them
by wearing a wig
and laughing in a foreign accent and i
escaped yes dear now i think you could
do with some more hair clips don't you
uh no well let's say half a dozen to be
on the safe side
said her mother coraline didn't say
anything
in the car on the way back home coraline
said
what's in that empty flat i don't know
nothing i expect
it probably looks like our flat before
we moved in empty rooms
do you think you can get into it from
our flat not unless you can walk through
brixton
oh they got home around lunchtime
the sun was shining although the day was
cold
coraline's mother looked in the fridge
and found a sandwich a tomato and a
piece of cheese
with green stuff growing on it there was
only a crust in the bread bin
i'd better dash down to the shops and
get some fish fingers or something
said her mother do you want to come no
so coraline suit yourself said her
mother
left then she came back and got her
passing car keys and went out again
coraline was bored she flipped through
the book her mother had been reading
about native people in a distant country
however every day they would take a
piece of white silk
and drawn them in wax then dip the silk
and dye
then drawn the wax some more and then
dye them some more
then boil the wax out in hot water and
then finally
throw the now beautiful cloth on a fire
and burn them to ashes
it seemed particularly pointless to
coraline but she hoped the people
enjoyed it
she was still bored and her mother
wasn't home yet
coraline got a chair and pushed it over
to the kitchen door
she climbed onto the chair and reached
up she got down
then got a broom from the broom cupboard
she climbed back on the chair
again and reached up with the brim [ __ ]
she climbed down from the chair and
picked up the keys
she smiled triumphantly then she leaned
the broom against the wall
and went into the drawing room the
family did not use the drawing room
they had inherited the furniture from
coraline's grandmother
along with a wooden coffee table a heavy
glass ash tray
and the oil painting of a bowl of fruit
coralline could never work out where
anyone would want to paint a bowl of
fruit other than that the room was empty
there were no knickknacks on the
mantelpiece no statues or clocks
nothing that made it feel comfortable or
lived in
the old black key felt colder than any
of the others
she pushed it into the keyhole it turned
smoothly with a satisfying clunk
corner stopped and listened she knew she
was doing something wrong
and she was trying to listen for her
mother coming back but she had nothing
then coraline put her hand on the
doorknob and turned it
and finally she opened the door
it opened onto a dark hallway
the bricks has gone as if they'd never
been there
there was a cold musty smell coming
through the open doorway
it smelled like something very old and
very slow
coraline went through the door she
wondered what the empty flat would be
like
if that was where the corridor led
carlin walked down the corridor and
easily
there was something very familiar about
it
the carpet beneath her feet was the same
carpet they had in their flat
the wallpaper was the same wallpaper
they had
the picture hanging in the hall was the
same picture they had hanging in there
or way at home
she hadn't left she shook her head
confused
she stared at the picture hanging on the
wall
no it wasn't exactly the same the
picture they had in their own hallway
showed it showed a boy in old-fashioned
clothes staring at some bubbles
but now the expression on his face was
different
he was looking at the bubbles as if he
was planning to do something
very nasty indeed to them and there was
something peculiar about his eyes
coraline stared at his eyes trying to
figure out what exactly was the
difference
she almost had it when somebody said
coraline it sounded like her mother
coraline went into the kitchen where the
voice had come from
a woman stood in the kitchen with her
back to coraline
she looked a little like coraline's
mother only
only her skin was white as paper
only she was taller and thinner only her
fingers were too long
and they never stopped moving and her
dark red fingernails were curved and
sharp
caught a line the woman said is that
you and then she turned around
her eyes were big black buttons
lunchtime coraline said the woman
who are you oscar line
i'm your other mother said the woman
go and tell your other father that lunch
is ready
she opened the door of the oven
suddenly coraline realized how hungry
she was
it smelled wonderful well go on
caroline went down the hall to where her
father's study was
she opened the door there was a man in
there
sitting at the keyboard with his back to
her
hello so coraline i
i mean she said to say the lunch is
ready
the man turned around his eyes were
buttons
big and black and shiny hello coraline
he said i'm starving
he got up and went with her into the
kitchen they sat at the kitchen table
and coraline's other mother brought them
lunch a
huge golden brown roasted chicken fried
potatoes tiny green peas
coraline shoveled the food into her
mouth it tasted wonderful
we've been waiting for you a long time
said coralines are the father
for me yes said that other mother
it wasn't the same without you but we
knew you'd arrive one day
and then we could be a proper family
would you like some more chicken
it was the best chicken that coraline
had ever eaten
her mother sometimes made chicken but it
was always out of a packet
all frozen and was very dry
and it never tasted of anything when
coraline's father cooked chicken
he brought real chicken but he did
strange things to it
like stirring it in wine or stuffing it
with prunes
or baking it in pastry and caroline
wouldn't
always refuse to touch it on principle
she took some more chicken i didn't know
i had another mother
said coraline cautiously of course you
do
everyone does so did the other mother
her black button eyes gleaming
after lunch i thought you might like to
play in your room with the rats
the rats from upstairs
colin had never seen a rat except in
television
she was quite looking forward to it this
was turning out to be a very interesting
day after all
after lunch her other parents did the
washing up
and coraline went down the hall to her
other bedroom
it was different from her bedroom at
home for a start it was painted in an
off-putting shade of green
and a peculiar shade of pink
coralline decided that she wouldn't want
to have to sleep in there
but that the color scheme was an awful
lot more interesting than the one in her
own bedroom there were all sorts of
remarkable things in there that she'd
never seen before
wind-up angels that floated around the
bedroom like startled sparrows
books with pictures that rised and
called and shimmered
little dinosaur skulls that chatted
their teeth as she passed
a whole toy box filled with wonderful
toys this is more like it
thought coraline she looked out of the
window outside the view was the same one
she saw from her bedroom
trees fields and beyond them on the
horizon distant purple hills
something black scurried across the
floor and vanished under the bed
coraline got down on her knees and
looked under the bed
50 little red eyes stared back at her
hello say coraline
are you the rats they came out from
under the bed
blinking their eyes in the light they
had short
soot black fur little red eyes pink
pores like tiny hands
and pink hairless tails like long smooth
worms
can you talk she asked
the largest blackest of the rats shook
his head
it had an unpleasant sort of a smile
coraline thought
well oscar coraline what do you
do the rats formed a circle
then they began to climb on top of each
other carefully but swiftly
until they had formed a pyramid with the
largest rat on top
the rats began to sing in high whisper
voices
we have teeth and we have tails we have
tails we have eyes
we were here before you fell you will be
here when we rise
it wasn't a pretty song coraline was
sure she's heard it before
or something like that although she was
unable to remember exactly where
then the pyramid fell apart and the rat
scampered
fast and black towards the door the
other
crazy old man upstairs was standing in
the doorway
holding a tall black hat in his hands
the rat scampered up him burrowing into
his pockets
into his shirt up his trouser leg down
his neck
the largest rat climbed up onto the old
man's shoulders
swung up on the long gray mustache past
the big black button
eyes and onto the top of the man's head
in
seconds the only evidence that the rats
were there at all
was the restless lumps under the man's
clothes forever sliding from place to
place across him
and there was still the largest rat who
stared down with glittering red eyes
at coinline from the man's head the old
man put his hat on
and the last rat was gone hello coraline
said the other old man i
heard you were here it is time for the
rats to have their dinner
but you can come up with me if you like
and watch them feed there was something
hungry in the old man's button eyes that
made coraline feel uncomfortable
no thank you she said i'm going outside
to explore
the old man nodded very slowly
coraline could hear the rats whispering
to each other
although she could not tell what they
were saying she was not certain that she
wanted to know what they were saying
her other parents stood in the kitchen
doorway as she walked down the corridor
smiling identical smiles and waving
slowly
have a nice time outside said her other
mother
we'll just wait for you here to come
back
said about the father when coraline got
to the front door
she turned back and looked at them they
were still watching her and waving and
smiling
coraline walked outside and down the
steps
[Music]
you